speaker is that tell us about to leave
early hey everyone congratulations I'm
waking up in time for my talk you should
all congratulate me for waking up on
time for my talk thank you
so I'm gonna talk about future here in
the standard model or if you want the
flash here title Fiat Emir from practice
to theory credit must go to Iran for
this wonderful freezing it is like
ingenious this is based on mostly on to
joint works one with granule a Justin
guy and Ron the other with Ron and
Daniel but more generally this has been
a super exciting research area over the
last couple of years there have been all
these works and in particular I think
there are a lot of exciting open
questions left to be tackled to
hopefully like borrowing from a loans
terminology from yesterday hopefully
there's a like many of you 20 papers on
stuff related to this that would be that
would be super nice
okay so I'll bore you for a couple of
slides with stuff you already know but
so we're talking about public coin
interactive protocols which means that
we have interactive protocol where every
verifier message is uniformly random and
satisfying the standard completeness and
soundness conditions so this is a model
of computation and we've known for a
long time that it's a super powerful
model of computation so this is just
like one phrasing of this of like of the
like meta statements that interactive
protocols are very powerful and fiat
ramier heuristic sort of turns this on
it on its head and asks do you actually
need to interact to do any of this stuff
and so we know in some settings that you
absolutely do need interaction in order
to achieve certain properties but
somewhat counter-intuitively fiat ramier
say that at least heuristically it turns
out you don't need interaction in a lot
of those cases so it's a some sort of
black magic that allows you to convert
and public coin interactive protocols
into non interactive ones so so here's
how it works start with an interactive
protocol on the left if yet jamia turns
it into a non interactive protocol in
the following way we have some hash
function that's is publicly known and
agreed upon between the prover of the
verifier and now the prover is going to
send an entire transcript of the
left-hand-side protocol in one shot and
the way you would the one way you can do
this is by computing a first message and
instead of waiting for the verifier to
say anything back just compute hash of
your first message and maybe the
instance and pretend that's what the
verifier sent to you then that allows
you to send your second proven message
like based on that bad verifier message
and then repeatedly just keep hashing
the transcript so far treat that as the
next verifier message and use this to
compute your next approver message so
this is one way for the prover to
produce an entire transcript of a
protocol in one shot and so then the
verifier can just can just check that
all of the hashes are computed correctly
and check that the public coin
transcript is accepting and accepts if
this holds so
yeah so so so what I what I mean is that
we don't have a proof right like one can
conjecture that if you start with a
sound protocol on the left and that you
get a sound protocol on the writes but
it should be a priori completely unclear
whether or not that's actually true
there's something people use I know
that's broken
yes which will we'll get to it then yes
so I mean so interactive protocol is
interactive protocol okay public coin
means that all of the verifier messages
are random strings there's no privates
verifier randomness so you need this
here in order for this compiler to make
any sense because the verify like when
you computes the verifier messages to be
hash of the transcripts there's no
secret randomness that you generated so
in order for this to like in order for
this to make sense the verifier needs to
be able to know whether or not to accept
the transcript without having any secret
states
do this this car isn't this I mean that
well that that how do you model the hash
function and we will we'll get to it so
but for now let's not let's not worry
too much about the model just imagine
that somebody has handed you a hash
function like we're using shot too and
we're happy okay so it is very hard to
overstate how influential this
methodology has been especially in
practical crypto and of course to the
practitioners here I don't actually have
to explain that to you presumably yeah
you know but so so why why is it so nice
so it's very powerful in the sense that
as I was explaining earlier interactive
protocols allow you to do a lot of
things that are priori non ins like that
you couldn't do on your own but now Fiat
Ramirez saying actually you could have
done these in one shot non interactive
protocols and and this is very useful so
there's very low overhead in the sense
that if you have a hash function which
is very efficient then the overhead over
doing the interactive protocol is very
low and it allows you to do a wide
variety of different things so three
specific things that I want to highlight
is that this gives you very efficient
signature schemes it gives you very
efficient non interactive zero-knowledge
arguments and it gives you what
previously called computationally sound
proofs or or snugs or you know any any
word describing these so these are three
very different things that fetch aamir
all fiat ramier allows you to do and our
goal in this work and in that long
sequence of works that you saw earlier
was to try to establish a stronger
theoretical basis for this
transformation so so far I've only said
that soundness is heuristic we preserved
so so so the question is what - what can
we prove about it so just before getting
to that - let me just in slightly more
detail highlights one of the three
applications that I just said so let's
talk about delegation so again apologies
for if all of you know this already but
but so a publicly verifiable non
interactive delegation scheme or two
pending on your like mood of the day you
might or might not want to call this a
snark is is something in the following
setting you have you have a week
verifier that wants to be convinced that
some instance X is in a language and and
you have now some sort of set up giving
you a common reference string and then a
one message argument system from prove
the verifier that is very short and
again publicly verifiable we don't want
any any secret state so so one way that
you can get such a scheme is by applying
Fiat ramier to the analogous object
accepts with interactions so an
interactive Pub public point interactive
arguments with very low communication
and we have these things either in the
computational setting the kilian
protocol and its derivatives or or in
the in the proof setting as well either
this the gkr protocol or the RR protocol
for bounded depth and bounded space
respectively and so you can apply fiat
ramier to any of these things and get a
candidate's non-internet snark for some
complexity class and there aren't very
many ways we know how to do this so one
is the theater near approach the other
is by taking the linear pcps etc and and
using some extract ability or knowledge
assumption and and this is basically it
as far as I know we have approaches in
these two families and that's the only
way we know how to get snarks so sofia
Amir is not only not only this pH Amir
like allow you to do many different
things like some of the things that'll
let it allows you to do cannot be done
by other means as far as we can tell or
at least are very difficult to do so
that's uh that's my pitch for the
applicability and the practitioners
could all argue that way better than me
but now I want to go back to the
question of is the fee at ramier
transform actually secure so all I've
said so far is that soundness is
heuristically preserved so so as as was
coming up in discussion before like the
key question to argue security is how
we're modeling this hash function that I
said is up in the sky
the proven verifier have access to you
so one can show that's in the random
Oracle model you get security so so so
what is the random Oracle model but very
briefly you model the hash function as a
uniformly random function and you have a
security model where the or the
adversarial prover only has query access
to this function so possibly a strong
modeling assumption but if you make it
then you can show that's the Fiat ramier
heuristic is provably secure in this
model for like basically in any
application that you care about not
quite true but almost true so so that's
nice so you could ask if we're done but
you know we're making a strong modeling
assumption here and and you can ask well
fine but what if you use a concrete hash
function you know either a single hash
function or maybe Sampo you could have a
model where you sample the hash function
from some family then you can ask if you
can prove security in the in the in the
standard sense and this turns out to be
a difficult question and a deep question
and and the very first answer is
definitely no this is what do you call
it impossible unconditionally
unconditionally impossible and so so
what do we know we know okay so so just
for terminology let's say a hash
function is fee HIV are compatible if
you can use it I'm sorry for a protocol
PI if you can do fetching me are using H
and PI then we know that by now that
there are specific public Oien
interactive protocols at constant round
so so you can do for your amusing a
random Oracle for them but there are
such protocols such that for any hash
function H or any family as have hash
functions that you want to sample H from
the yet Sameer protocol is provably
insecure unsound so that's a super
unfortunate on the other hand the the
only protocols for which we have
unconditional counter example
demonstrates counter example Sofia to me
are quite contrived not something that
you would actually use so the question
you know is Fiat Samir does Fiat ramier
work for any protocol that you care
about personally is still a valid
question although although there's this
TCC work this year on fee a treatment
for kilee and that starts to say even
then maybe not but that's a I'll leave
that for for other people to discuss but
at least the the old counter examples
are very contrived so okay so what's up
I mean this is not my results you can
wait or any of the author's here James
is here writes I mean but their result
is that is that if there are there is
like for example there's a bad
Killian hash function like hash function
for the for message Killian protocol
such that no matter how you instantiate
the PCP and no matter how you
instantiate the future meerkat hash
function you you don't get soundness I
think that's what it is right
so still somewhat contrived but let's
contrast okay so so one option after
seeing the Baraka and Shafi il theorems
are just to give up and go home
we could do that but another thing we
can do is try to identify what the
problem is and and try to prove that
Fiat ramier works in certain cases in
particular we want to prove that it
works for protocols that we care about
so here's one property that that we can
focus on so the counter examples are for
interactive arguments that is the
interactive protocol that we're trying
to compile only satisfies computational
centers so one could conjecture that I
mean you could mean the actual mirror is
also just a conjecture before but you
could just boldly conjecture that's if
you assume that the interactive protocol
satisfies statistical soundness rather
than computational soundness that that
then it's possible to instantiate Fiat
Shamir
a priori it might be sort of unclear why
this is the rights property to isolates
like waiawa you know why do you want to
conjecture soundness when you just wrote
down a counter example but it's it's a
conjecture you could make and for the
talk we're going for this talk we're
going to focus on trying to get Fiat gem
here when we starts with an interactive
proof so this is not the end of the
story even if this question we're
completely answered like the real
question or I don't know about v real
question but one really important
question is can we do from here for
Killian because we want snogs in the
standard model and the rest of the talk
is not going to get at least snarks for
all of NP in the standard model that
that can't happen if we're compressing a
proof instead of an argument but this is
at least a starting points where we can
see see if we can prove anything in this
in this case okay so an advantage of
focusing on the case of interactive
proofs instead of interactive arguments
is that there's actually a concrete
property of the theater mayor hash
function that we can isolate such that
like a typical security property like in
the game base security property such
that if the hash function satisfies the
security property then it provably
instantiates fetch amir
so that's super nice it's called
correlation intractability Ron is here
so I'm sort of morally obligated to
indoctrinate you into the cult of
correlation intractability and sorry I
mean really oh I see
okay but in it so in any case I will
voluntarily indoctrinate you all into
the Church of correlation and
tractability so so here's the security
property so a hash family H is
correlation intractable for some sparse
relation R so the relation has an input
X and an output Y if the following holds
given a randomly sampled hash function
from the family it should be hard to
find an input X such that X and the hash
of X if you said that to Y satisfies the
relation R so so just in more and more
symbols the adversary should be able to
output such an input X with negligible
only negligible probability and and note
that I certainly have a sparse relation
so by sparse I mean that for every X
there are very few Y which satisfy the
relation along with X which translates
to saying that random Oracle's are
correlation interactable that's that's
what sparsity guarantees you so so an
example a specific example that's going
to matter in this talk is forgetting
about relations just thinking about
functions so by that I mean just if you
have a function from inputs to outputs
you can consider the relation of all
pairs X comma f of X so this is a very
sparse relation there's only one Y for
every X
so the first thing that I want to show
you is that if a hash family is
correlation intractable for all sparse
relations so the the previous statement
holds for every sparse R then we
probably can compile Interpublic coin
interactive proofs constant around
public land interactive proofs into non
interactive arguments v FV h amir that
we can and then we can prove security
based on the correlation intractability
of the hash family so i'm just going to
show you the 3d message case it
generalizes quite reasonably but the
proof is super simple in the three
message case so let's take a three this
farce relation X H of X so how can H be
so this thing yeah the security property
is you tell me the relation then I
sample the hash function
oh so you sample it from a random yes
yes it is a distribution on hash
functions so you first sample a relation
with high probability the function
sampled from the family relation is
adversarial family the one you sample is
good yes baby since was the random
Oracle which you can only with which you
can defeat the correlation in fact a
minute good so I mean well the random
Oracle definitely can't do for yet
ramier for Killian sorry that's right
that correlation in tractability doesn't
seem to be sufficient to do fetch Amir
for Killian it also isn't sufficient to
do Fiat Amir for the counter example
protocols which random Oracle's are
[Music]
okay but in any case let me show you
this proof it's super simple so take a
three message protocol alpha beta gamma
where beta is a random string and we
suppose it's sound we want to show that
the future mere protocol on the writes
sorry oh shoot yes on your right is
sound so so what do we want to say like
what is sound this mean means the prover
can't produce this alpha and gamma so
that alpha beta gamma is a good is a
good transcript so here's how we can
argue this just consider a relation
where the inputs are alphas and the
outputs are betas and the relation is
satisfied if there exists any gamma at
all making the transcripts Alpha Beta
Gamma accepting for X so in order to be
done we need to argue that the relation
is sparse if this relation is sparse
then the correlation intractability of H
with respect to R will guarantee the
soundness of the right hand side
protocol and this is because like the
correlation intractability will say it's
hard to find and a first message alpha
such that there even exists a gamma like
in the world that you could write down
making the transcript accepting so a
correlation in tractability suffices as
long as this relation is sparse but the
sparsity of the relation follows
directly from the soundness of the three
message protocol because that exactly
says that no soundness says that no
matter what alpha you pick and this is
statistical soundness that's important
so not or what alpha you pick for a
random beta there will not exist a gamma
that's what the left-hand-side sound
this says because it's soundness against
unbounded provers so that exactly
translates to this relation being sparse
and so correlation in tractability will
get a soundness of the future mere
protocol
sorry you mean this argument so I mean I
mean I mean this approach that like the
proof definitely fails because we can't
argue the relation is sparse yeah so so
so here's something you can do it's
maybe not maybe not so nice but what you
can do is have a computational analog of
correlation and tractability where you
you know have to have some notion of a
relation being computationally sparse
it's got to be you know a random
relation now but a random relation can
be computationally sparse if it's hard
to find things in the relation and and
then you could hypothesize correlation
and tractability for computationally
sparse relations but it doesn't hold
sorry what is the non interactive
argument so who's choosing this age from
the family so there are two options
either you imagine you have set up
choosing the H I mean it doesn't depend
on the like it it's it's sampled
independently of the language and
everything so you could have set up or
you can have the verifier pick h if
because we're only talking about
soundness right now now if you
additionally care about things like zero
knowledge then you have to worry about
the verifier picking h but but for now
by non-interactive I just mean one of
those two things I let the verifier have
like so you could have the very effect
like this hash function can be picked
once and for all for example if you want
to do many things so there's like
somebody has to pick a hash function
once and then you can have protocols you
know you can compile any protocol
however many times you want in one
message one set you you first need to
fix the relation before you randomly
choose the
yes so you will run into trouble if if
you want to prove things about the hash
function right so that's that that's
that's what your thing about Stu saying
right so that the standard soundness
won't apply if you want to prove things
about the about the hash function
although sometimes we can even argue
adaptive soundness which would be
worrying about the things that's you're
talking about it's in the uniform random
stream model right so big this age
depends on your hash function if it's a
public point hash function then yes so
in the examples that like in the
examples of hash functions that we event
let me write down later
all of them turn out to be public coin
so we will get things in the uniform
random stream model
more questions
all right so this shows that correlation
intractability suffice is for Fiat
ramier at least for three methods
protocols you can extend it to constant
rounds public line protocols interactive
proofs so this should hopefully convince
you of the utility of the security
notion so this is quite different from
the arguments case because there is a
security property we can phrase that
suffice is and that also isn't just like
unconditionally unsatisfiable that's uh
that would be bad too so let's let's go
back to the question so we wanted to
know if we can instantiate Fiat ramier
for interactive proofs in the standard
model and what the previous couple of
slides tell you is that if we have a
correlation in tractable hash family
then the answer is yes so maybe maybe
that gives us some hope unfortunately
the answer still like so the question as
stated was open for quite some time I
think there were I'm trying to think
so probably the magic functions papers
that's back in 99 was already asking you
know if you could do fiat ramier for
very specific protocols so this is post
correlation intractability I think it
was clear at the time Oh somebody older
than me would understand better than me
but I think probably since the late 90s
is the question that people were
thinking about there was no progress for
quite a while until about 2016 I would
say there were some negative results I
don't want to exactly get into the
details but there are some kinds of
black box and possibility results for
instantiating future me or even this
even in this restricted setting so that
might scare you I think the scarier
thing is that's take any protocol you
want like take for example I mean you
can talk about Killian that seems hard
but you could also talk about it's just
like classical zero knowledge protocols
from the 80s take any specific one of
them that you once asked can we do Fiat
Jameer for it any specific one of them
and there was no answer for you know
until quite recently which i think is
pretty bizarre but but there was
basically nothing new
this protocol is a commitment scheme so
you mean when you say instantiating the
new info so if so if it's the NP
protocols yes but you could also talk
about the protocol for QR or discrete
log or lwe or something like that then
there's no commitment build it and the
commitment scheme is implicit okay so
but yes you could also ask for like the
3-coloring or hamiltonicity protocol you
know use now our commitment or use the
discrete log one message commitment
anything like this and then you could
ask
okay so so but we had nothing we had
basically nothing this is what I was
just saying and oh and so and this is
related to the question of whether zero
knowledge composes in parallel because
in this magic functions paper showed
that if you can do Fiesta mirror for any
of these protocols to think of parallel
repetition of a classical three messages
your knowledge protocol its provably not
zero knowledge if you can do fetching
mere four it's and so this would resolve
questions about composition of zero
knowledge for natural protocols there
were there were unnatural counter
examples already but it was open for
these natural protocols
so what's going on very very strange
very call it a very strange state of
affairs but what I want to talk to you
about for the rest of the for the rest
of today is that in the last few years
we've actually come up with positive
results and it's super exciting so so
first we had positive results under what
I'll call strong assumptions and I'll
explain much more about what that means
so just to take a couple of theorem
statements from one of the one of the
papers so we can instantiate correlation
and tractable hash functions and
therefore do Fiat ramier by either
making very strong but still simple and
meaningful assumptions or by focusing on
specific protocols of interest error and
by or I I sort of mean and /or you can
do either of these things or both of
these things and I really want to
highlight the second of these it really
matters what protocol you're trying to
compile like it's hurt like and maybe
maybe this is obvious in retrospect but
doing theater Mir for some like even
when you focus already on interactive
proofs it turns out at least as far as I
can tell that doing theater Mir for some
interactive proofs is way easier at
least proving security is way easier
than doing fetch Amir for other
interactive proofs and like one of the
very key ideas in these works has been
trying to isolate some nice properties
of interactive proofs that we like such
that there are interactive proofs that
we care about satisfying the properties
and we can instantiate Fiocchi Amir for
protocol satisfying these properties
so let me talk about the certain
examples yes and we'll get it we'll get
to it but for example the the GMR like
the quadratic residue Oxley protocol for
example like some classical zero
knowledge protocols fall into this also
as it turns out the g'kar delegation
protocol we can do fiat ramier for that
as well
okay so let me talk about the
assumptions so this is again this is the
strong assumptions section there will be
a standard assumptions section later but
for now like this this first work is
making and this first work and many of
the preceding works sorry for being
somewhat anachronistic but many works
are making hardness assumptions of the
following form which I call optimal
hardness so like optimal hardness of
some problem intuitively means that's
polynomial time adversary can't break
the assumption with better than some
kind of trivial probability so trivial
probability essentially means guessing
some secrets and the assumption will be
that you can't do any better than
guessing the secret uniformly at random
possibly with some polynomial in your
description length overhead so it's
quite a strong assumption definitely not
a standard assumption but so the example
you should think of is if you have some
one-way function f like the optimal
hardness of f means that you can't
invert f with better than poly and
security parameter over to to the
security parameter probability where the
input length to this function is lambda
so so it's a strong assumption but on
the other hand okay so a couple of
things I am talking about polynomial
time algorithms here so for a lot of for
a lot of problems like this screech log
or lwe if you run in some exponential
time but not fully exponential time like
basically there's something better than
a 2 to the lambda algorithm for most of
the problems that we care about it's not
exactly 2 to the lamb that's like maybe
to cool em 2 over 2 sometimes worse
things but here this assumption is about
polynomial time algorithms and these
exponential time algorithms don't seem
to translate to polynomial time
algorithms that work with non-trivial
success probability so the assumptions
are not like broken right off the bat so
in particular both like search lwe
for certain parameter settings and
discrete log over elliptic curves like
in the state-of-the-art sat like in the
state-of-the-art as far as attacks go
don't about like the assumptions are not
violated they're true as far as we know
it's not it's not obvious but in this so
one of the earlier papers around you a
Leo and Ron they analyzed it first
standard discrete log and they at least
said that it's almost broken I forget if
they said it was exactly broken but it's
almost broke he said standard discrete
log I seen that to mean like ZP star I
think it's not obvious but it's it but I
think it has been analyzed and it looks
at least almost broken over like over ZP
star discrete log over ZP star you can
get something non-trivial as opposed to
like discrete log over elliptic curves
or search lwe like there is like
absolutely like I don't know of any
attacks that are better than literally
guessing over and over again
okay so that's the assumption that we
make in this first work so here are here
are two results now so we can get a
publicly verifiable non-interactive
delegation for bounded depth computation
assuming the optimal hardness of some
fully homomorphic encryption scheme and
so by optimal hardness of this I mean
that's given a public key and a
ciphertext it should be very hard to
find the secret key this essentially
corresponds to and a search lwe
assumption where you're also given out
some sort of circular secure encryptions
in a reggae of encryption scheme so it's
search lwe hardness with a bit of
circular security thrown in so and the
way we do it is by showing that under
this assumption we can write down a hash
function that instantiates fiat ramier
for the g'kar interactive delegation
scheme for bounded depth computation and
again you know if you care about these
things we can get the nice things like
adaptive soundness and rely on a uniform
CRS for the delegation but but in any
case I think we should if you if you
care about these things you should
probably use shot too instead of this
hash function right but but I did I
think it's a nice sure okay that's
that's there so so so we get nice
properties in theory land I would not
recommend using this in practice but
like I said the goal from the beginning
is to establish a theoretical basis for
pH Amir so I'm sorry I'm certainly not
focusing on practical efficiency in this
talk
okay so that's a delegation result we
also show you can get mythix
all NP languages assuming now the
roughly the same thing but forget the
circular security so it's just that's a
search lwe is super super hard so and
and we do it by infinity nafech amir for
a particular instantiation of the
classical 3-coloring protocol and by a
particular instantiation I mean that I
pick the commitment scheme to be
something specific and again nice
properties can get either statistical
zero knowledge or adaptive soundness and
have a uniform CRS again yes the second
thing is music the first thing is to
sing this yes this is so I'm just going
through like these were these are
results based on optimal hardness and
then later we'll get results nowhere so
okay but like yeah so we have to like
there are two sets of results in this
line of work one word one set of results
is based on optimal hardness assumptions
and then later punchline we were able to
get some results based on standard
assumptions but for now I'm talking
about optimal hardness and what you can
get from it yeah in particular again
like spoilers we still don't know how to
do fetch aamir for this 3-coloring
protocol based on standard assumptions
still open
okay but but the main takeaway points I
want you to get from this slide is that
we wrote down delegation schemes and and
musics that are secure unless there are
better lwe algorithms in the state of
the art so it's a nice win-win
so so I want to give you a bit a bit
about how we how we prove this
apologies for skipping over like many
things but I want to show you a little
bit about how we prove these kinds of
results how we're actually showing
future mirai come in can be instantiated
so so here's here's a hash function that
you could think about a hash Jenny could
think about eat of the hash function is
going to be some cypher text for some
encryption scheme so C is the key to the
hash function an input to the hash
function is going to be an encryption
key or let's say we have symmetric
encryption so so a key for the
encryption scheme so I have just swapped
so I've swapped some things around and
so so what's the hash function it's the
only thing it could be so if you if you
have a key as input in a ciphertext
as your hash key the hash output is the
decryption of the ciphertext under the
key so hash functions like of this
flavor already proposed by Fiat engineer
back in the ease of course without
proofs but but the idea has been around
and yes there is no future in your paper
so so what we're able to show is that if
the encryption scheme in question is
super strong namely it's satisfying some
sort of optimal security condition then
this hash function is correlation
intractable and depending on how strong
of an assumption you make it can
actually be correlation intractable for
all relations if you Fiat Emir for all
proofs but then the court the assumption
is going to be correspondingly very
strong so so let me show you how the
proof works very briefly so I haven't
defined anything but I think somehow
showing the proof is better than showing
the definitions so so 1ru that's if this
hash function is not correlation
intractable then there's something wrong
with the encryption scheme meaning that
it's it's not a perfect encryption
scheme so so how is it going to work
here here's the here's the reduction
it's sort of the only thing sort of one
of the only things you could think of oh
I should say this so this proof first
appeared in the CCR our paper the proof
technique I would say belongs with Yale
guy and Ron from the previous paper
there they're doing there they're not
arguing about this hash function but
they're making it they're using a very
similar proof idea in some sense that
sort of got all of this fiat Shamir
instantiation started so I think a lot
of credit should go to these works but
but here's that here's the proof suppose
the hash function is broken meaning
that's you get a random ciphertext and
the adversary is able to produce a key
such that some relation is satisfied by
the key and the decryption of the
ciphertext along with the key so that's
breaking correlation intractability now
let's let's let's break the encryption
so that sort of the encryption scheme is
broken what is going to be broken I'm
going to show you that if you're given
an encryption of some key dependent
message and the encryption scheme so
that there's gonna be some function f
I'm going to hand you an encryption of F
of the secret key under the secret key
and I'm going to show you how to recover
the secret key with better than guessing
probability so so that's like so so
that's what we want to do and the
reduction is sort of the the first like
the the only thing you could do if
you're given a random ciphertext you
know you're trying to break the
encryption scheme just feed it to this
adversary get out some some key and hope
that this key is actually the secret key
that was hidden the secret key they are
supposed to be looking for so like this
hash function adversary hands out some
key it's got its guarantees that it's
buy some property and you can just hope
that it's the secret they're randomly
sampled secret key from before and so
you'll output this key and hope that you
win that's the reduction sounds maybe oh
maybe sounds too good to be true but but
it turns out that you can show that this
breaks the encryption scheme at least a
little bit and the and the okay so I
haven't entirely specified what's going
on I said there's some function I
haven't told you what the function is
here's the function it's a
a randomized function given an X it
samples a random Y satisfying the
relation with X and this should make
sense because of what the adversary is
looking for the adversary is looking for
for a key such that key and decryption
of the ciphertext satisfies the relation
so the function at least is compatible
with this and I will this I agree that
you should be unhappy and I will discuss
[Laughter]
you should always be unhappy in research
so you can do more ok so this is the
function as pointed out it is
inefficient but so let me let me say a
little bit about the proof so what's
like what is this C star this this this
ciphertext hand it to you like or what
is that what is the hash function
defined by the C star what does it look
like it's not a random ciphertext right
it's an encryption of a function of the
secret key under the secret key not
totally random but intuitively you can
think of this this hash function as a
random hash function from the family
sort of conditioned on there being some
planted bad points satisfying the
relation in it like this encryption of f
of K under K is one of these bad points
so intuitively you might think of this
ciphertext defining a hash function
which is random subjects to having this
planted bad point in it so now
intuitively the argument will be that
since the adverse that the inner
adversary is guaranteed to find a bad
point if your plants had bad points
looks like a random one then the
probability that he outputs the secret
key you were looking for should be
roughly his probability divided by the
number of bad points in the world the
number of bad points in the world is
much less than the number of keys in the
world so intuitively you're going to be
guessing the key with non-trivial
probability and so this is informal but
you can basically argue this and you and
this is how the proof works
so we need some additional hypotheses
about the encryption scheme for this to
work but it's not too bad like you can
write down the encryption scheme like
they're not the additional properties
are fairly mild so this is how some of
the some of the works proceeded but I do
want to highlight exactly this issue
that was pointed out like in general
this F is an inefficient function I'm
saying sample you like give an X sample
a uniformly random bad point for X this
is quite enough it like in general
you're gonna have to enumerate sense and
then sample which means that if your
eventual goal is to prove this based on
a standard assumption you're going to be
in trouble but at least intuitively
you're going to be in trouble because
arguing about security with a universal
quantifier over inefficient functions in
the setup is sometimes quite difficult
so I don't mean to say that it is
impossible to make this go through so
like if your goal is still to do Fiat
Jameer for all proofs get correlation
tractability for all relations you're
gonna have to deal with this problem but
this already suggests that it might be
easier to identify situations where F
can be an efficient function that might
make it easier to prove security and so
this is exactly what we do in so in this
in order to get the delegation and it's
the music results that I've already
showed you we exactly do that so so take
your relation R we say it's efficiently
sample if the function f that I just
told you is efficient and immediately
that already like that already tells you
the security proof from the previous
slide is already relying on a slightly
weaker not or not just like a noticeably
weaker assumption actually than before
now in order to get Fiat ramier right
off the bat you only have to assume that
encryption scheme satisfies this strong
KDM security with respect to efficient
KTM functions so that's a starting point
and basically in this work we push we do
some heavy lifting on top of that to
weaken the assumption as much as
possible for example all the way down to
search L to the search lwe hardness
so-so
so we so we first do this we show that
under these nice assumptions we can get
hash functions that are correlation
intractable
for all efficiently sample relations and
so but that's not the end of the story
because our priori it's totally unclear
if these are useful for anything but we
also show that's this weaker form of
correlation intractability still
suffices to do fiat Jameer for
interactive proof that we care about I
mean I mean no no I'm so far I mean the
ones that I've only that I've referenced
before so lwe is super hard so so very
quickly I want to say a little bit about
the delegation result before moving on
because I said we do fiat ramier for the
gkr protocol which is this nice anything
of it as some check based protocol to do
delegation for bounded death compounded
depth computation but there are already
like some worries namely this is not a
constant round protocol it's a super
constant around protocol so already you
have to worry about whether future
mirror even makes sense in the setting
and you can show it works in the random
Oracle model I think this was already
known that it worked in the random
Oracle model but it's not clear of
correlation intractability suffices the
previous proof doesn't generalize to the
setting and then on top of that if you
can if you can in fact rely on
correlation intractability you then need
to make sure that whatever relation you
wrote down is actually efficient so
that's we can at least if you want to
simplify the assumptions you're making
and so just very quickly I want to
mention like one nice idea that came out
of the the work which is notion of round
by round soundness so whatever I'm
related to the unambiguous soundness
that guy was talking about but a
different flavor so a protocol has round
by round soundness
if intuitively you want to say that
there's some doomed state such that's
like in the soundness analysis you
should start out in a doomed state and
then in every round whenever the
verifier sends you something it is a
very low probability of you escaping the
doomed state so and then at the end if
the full transcript is dooms then the
actual verifier should reject the
so so you can you can see fairly easily
that's the some Czech protocol and the
g'kar protocol satisfy this notion of
round by round soundness it should be
yes yes yes that is this slide so so
just very quickly like I want to show
that's like this soundness even though
you have a super super constant number
of rounds still suffice like you can
still do the auctioneer using
correlation intractability it's a very
simple arguments
once you've like thought about that like
once you phrase the definition that's
the right way the argument is very
simple namely think about a relation
where inputs are partial transcripts and
outputs are verifier messages and the
relation is satisfied if you start out
doomed but you end up not doomed round
by round soundness exactly just said
that this relation is sparse and
correlation intractability for this
relation will sort of directly
translates to soundness of the fiat
ramier protocol i don't want to like do
it in too much detail but this is but
you can show this works and then so okay
this is this is what Yael is saying so
you need somehow the the the the low
probability of becoming not doomed to
outweigh the number of rounds so that
you can Union bounce them exactly what
yes
okay and and so as I was saying some
check and g'kar you can show fall into
this framework the other thing I said
you want to worry about was sampling of
the relation so this is the relation and
you can check that in that in the case
of g'kar you can sample the relation in
time pali T where T is the time to
deterministically decide this language
and so what's super nice for us is that
because g'kar is considering delegation
a restricted setting where you actually
have polynomial time computation in the
first place this is an efficiently
sample relation you can hope to apply
future Mir based on the framework I've
written down already okay so that's all
I want to say about super strong
assumptions question so so in order to
get reasonable delegation right you need
the run time of the hash function to be
independent or at least have only a
logarithmic dependence on this time T
right otherwise you don't have any real
delegation so there's a subtlety that I
skipped over which is that you there are
two like kinds of hash functions you can
have one is a compact hash function
where the description and the runtime is
independent of the sampling time of the
relation and the other is a non compact
hash function where this is not the case
right like I said I want a correlation
tractability for all efficiently sample
relations and but to get delegation I
also need the hash function description
and runtime to be independent of the
sampling time this is why the two
assumptions for the delegation the music
results are not the same you need to
make the stronger assumption in order to
get this compactness property but then
on the other hand for the if you if you
if you don't care about the sickness
then you could you could even you know
specify a time down on the sampler first
and then write down a hash function
afterwards and and this is what allows
us to rely on search lwe for the music
results
okay so that's all I want to say on
optimal hardness based results and the
remaining time I want to talk about
standard assumptions so it turns out
surprise that we can actually
instantiate Fiat ramier in very special
cases under standard assumptions so
until now or even now we don't know how
to apply this to delegation but we do
know how to do that we do know how to
apply Fiat ramier to classical Ana's
verifier zero knowledge protocols and to
get out musics afterwards this is what
we know how to do so in the two
protocols I wanna highlights are exactly
going to be some variants of the
hamiltonicity protocol and the and the
classical quadratic residue also be
protocol and we're the second thing you
care about possibly like if you're
looking for counter examples to zero
knowledge parallel repetition which I
get the feeling I think is cooler than
those two other people do but I'm the
one giving the talk so in case this is
somehow like not in case some of you
have missed this lwe based non
interactive zero knowledge is not
something that we knew how to do before
this and oh did I skip over the
assumption I did the assumption is that
we need a fully homomorphic encryption
scheme which is circular secure so the
same assumption that you need to get
unbounded fully homomorphic encryption
but satisfying a quantitatively standard
level of security so the the same
assumption that you need to get
unbounded fhe this is our assumption and
then in a follow-up work [ __ ] and Chien
actually got rid of the circular
security assumption and based the hash
function on plain lwe
so we had known is extreme lwe before
this I think it's pretty bizarre that it
turned out that the way to get tuned is
expand lwe was to not go through for
example the the hidden bits model or
anything like this but to do Fiat ramier
possibly a little bizarre and and still
this is the only way we know how to do
newzik space nlw is by going through
fetching here so I said this already
even more nice things we get a dual mode
music so you can have either statistical
soundness or statistical zero knowledge
this should sound a little strange
because like even a random Oracle
doesn't give you a statistically sound
protocol like necessarily because there
exists bad points like when you like in
the entirely random case when you use a
random Oracle there will exist false
accepting proofs they're accepting
proofs on false statements but somehow
we can actually even get statistical
soundness by playing around with the lwe
so how do we do it we restrict our
notion of correlation intractability to
be even like for an even smaller class
of relations than we did before so
recall earlier the class of relations
that I cared about was where those where
you could efficiently sample a bad
outputs given an arbitrary inputs now
I'm going to ask her even more I'm going
to say forget relations think about only
functions and then in addition assume
that the function or we're dealing with
functions that are efficient so it's
like efficient sampling Enda like
extreme sparsity thrown on top you could
think of it that way so that that's how
we've restricted ourselves further so
under the assumption under the circular
secure fhe we construct a hash family
which is correlation intractable for all
functions of a a priori bounded size and
then we show that this still suffice is
two gets music's afterwards so I don't
have that much time but I want to say a
little bit about how we do this to you
it's it's it's actually a very simple
proof so so the first thing that you
should notice is that because we focused
on getting correlation intractability
for functions the problem looks
noticeably easier actually
so what do I want I want a hash function
H such that it's hard or a family such
that it's hard for every F it's hard to
find X such the hash of x equals f of X
so here's here's a dumb idea if I said
hash of X to be 1 plus f of X then it's
correlation intractable for F that's a
that you should believe of course the
problem is that this hash function
description depends on the relation and
I actually wanted the opposite thing
right so I wanted a hash function such
that for all relations you can't do this
but so that's what we want and we can so
the the idea is basically to put f
inside a home morphic encryption so that
you don't know what the f is and then
somehow you will have a hash function
that is simultaneously all of these
that's the idea so this gives you a
property that's stronger than
correlation intractability
that we call somewhere it statistical
correlation intractability you should
think of it as directly analogous to
somewhere statistically binding hash
functions as compared to collision
resistant hash functions so what is it
there's a there should be a way for
generating keys that depends on the
function f such that no matter what
function f you start with you can't like
the keys are indistinguishable so maybe
there's some natural distribution of
keys and all the F dependent keys are
indistinguishable from the natural keys
and when you start with a key that
depends on the function you get this
correlation intractability property
statistically there will not exist any X
satisfying this equation and and we
construct this object again you should
believe that this implies correlation
and tractability at the standard like
one-step hybrid arguments that this
suffices for correlation intractability
so let me show you how we do it
here's homework encryption hopefully
you've seen this before
you can encrypt inputs apply functions
and decrypt and get out f of X as I said
we're going to assume circular security
which which technically for us means
that's give it that encryption of a
secret key looks like encryption of 0 so
here's here's the hash function it's
actually super simple so take this home
Wharf encryption scheme the hash key is
going to be a public key along with an
encryption of the secret key and an
encryption of some function G that you
care about so as I said before we're
gonna think about sampling a hash key
depending on some function f the way
we're going to do it is by writing down
this object where G is some function
that depends on F in order to hash in
and put X you do the thing that you
would expect Paul morphic evaluates the
function G on the input X that's
something you can do so at the end you
get some encryption of G of X and the
and G can additionally take as and put
the secret key because we've put the
secret key inside the cipher text
so an honest key you can think of as G
being all zero function and when you
want to generate a key which is
correlation intractable for F you should
pick this function which is take X take
the secret key decrypt X using the
secret key and then flip the bit this
should look very much like the original
f of X plus one that I wrote down but I
have thrown into this decryption on top
so so here's here's the hash function I
claim that it satisfies the properties
we want well first of all definitely
keys with different G's are
indistinguishable assuming that the
encryption scheme is circuit is secure
right that's G is inside a red box you
don't know what it is as long as it's
circular secure so all that's left to
show is that if you generate keys using
a function f that the resulting hash
function is correlation intractable for
F what this means is that I want to say
the hash of X is never equal to f of X
but but here's why if you decrypt hash
of X necessarily you get this evaluated
function by correctness of homework
homomorphic evaluation and this function
I literally set up to be 1 plus
decryption of f of X so that means that
it's definitely not equal to decryption
of f of X right so hash of X and f of X
decrypt to opposite plain texts so they
can't be equal and that's it that's the
whole proof after all that's the the
proof is actually very simple
okay so finally that was our hash
function
I still haven't said how you get music
out of it I haven't said how to compile
classical zero knowledge protocols so in
in in a few sentences we compile a class
of protocols that we abstract out as
trapdoor Sigma protocols so so what are
these take a three message protocol and
the crs model now so there's gonna be
some CRS is going to be a CRS for the
commitment scheme or at least in some of
the cases it will be so it should
satisfy two properties one is is a
standard for Sigma protocol special
soundness that is for every for every
first message there's at most one one
challenge that you can successfully
cheat on in the soundness case so this
is standard but then on top of that I
want to say that this bad second message
is efficiently computable from the first
message so this should make sense if
you're thinking about the kind of
correlation intractability we just
worked with it should make sense that
this is a property that would be nice
for us but naively that the naive way
that you would try to write down this
definition does not make any sense
namely the bad second message can't
possibly be efficiently publicly
computable as a function of the first
message this way at least if you're
dealing with zero knowledge protocols
intuitively this should definitely
contradict the zero knowledge like being
able to compute things like this so the
way that we get around this is that we
say it's not efficiently publicly
computable but given a trap door for the
CRS or maybe maybe also a trap door like
based on the instance maybe also like
give away the witness too but if you
have some trap door that's based on the
CRS and the witness then it's possible
for this function to be efficiently
computable without violating anything so
and this isn't just something in theory
this is something that we can actually
instantiate just like take the standard
Blum protocol for hamiltonicity
instantiate the commitment scheme with a
commitment scheme that has a trapdoor so
a public encryption scheme then you'll
get exactly well the first property was
already true it so it's a one bit
challenge
so it's fine and the efficient
computability is just so-so
so what is the what is the what is the
function f given a commitment to some
graph you wanted to decide if the graph
has a cycle or not it's right that's not
not the right way okay you want to that
what I want to say yes or say given a
graph in a permutation okay let's do it
this way given a graph in a permutation
decide if the permutation applied to the
graph is the original graph or not
that's like the fun but that will
determine which challenge you can or
cannot answer and that's something you
can compute if you know what was
committed to so if you have a trapdoor
for the commitment scheme this whole
thing becomes an efficiently computable
function so this satisfies the
definition that I wrote down and now in
again one line we're going to show that
the H Amir works for this product for
protocol satisfying this property using
the hash function that we wrote down so
again we have a three message protocol
we want to show that the Fiat Amir
protocol is sound and we want to use
correlation intractability for efficient
functions well here's the here's the
here's the relation or the function the
the function is exactly the bad
challenge function that I just talked
about so the relation is pairs alpha
beta where alpha is the first message
and beta is the second message and the
relation is satisfied if beta is equal
to the bad challenge associated to alpha
I just said that given a trapdoor at
least this is efficiently computable and
you can use this to directly argue the
soundness of the fiat ramier protocol
just using the correlation
intractability of h for efficient
functions and this this is the whole now
you've seen the entire proof now like in
the slide you've seen the whole purse
so very quickly so I showed a whole
bunch of works on correlational
tractability and fetching me earlier
there's in fact even more this wasn't
even one of the works because this is
more of an application than that
construed in a construction per se but
but so you already heard earlier in the
workshop about how you can use Fiat
Zamir for the for the some Czech
protocol to get P Pat Hartness which is
really nice and they are able to use
like a very slight modification of one
of our hash functions in order to like
give a candidate's hard P pad just like
distribution that's hard in P pad as I
said theatre for some Czech is generally
is the the tool or the the assumption
that they use to get it yes I yes I'm
just being informal here it's it's it's
it's it soft it's basically the same
thing they have to slightly modify it
because of this inefficient prove your
problem yeah and then as I mentioned the
standard assumptions results the one
that we based on circular secure fhe was
later like improved to rely only on
standard lwe they were very clever like
they they're taking the same approach
but they but they realized how to
instantiate the even like basically this
like alright babe they realize how to
instantiate our framework without
relying on circular security which
sounds very like I don't know I thought
about it and I didn't see how to get rid
of the secret key but these guys were
smarter and realize how to get rid of
the secret key from this from this
framework so just to conclude in this
talk I wanted to explain to you a bit
about how Fiat ramier for proofs can be
provably instantiated and the two like
ways that we do this are either I'm
making very strong assumptions or by
laser focusing on specific protocols
that are easier to work with but still
possibly useful so things that we care
about and again I want to highlight the
way that we do this
is by focusing on correlation
intractability for special classes of
relations that are that makes it easier
to instantiate the security property
with a proof I think there are a ton of
open questions here are a few the
3-coloring protocol I still don't know
how to do fetch aamir for the 3-coloring
protocol with any commitment scheme
under standard assumptions that would be
nice like right now there's a difference
between the blum protocol and the gmw
3-coloring protocol and this doesn't
make any intuitive sense to me we should
be able to do it for both yes yes we're
right now we only have like the only
standard assumptions based hash function
we have worked for functions and and the
3-coloring protocol like you can't think
about in terms of functions there are
too many bad challenges but I'm not sure
that this is a fundamental problem or
just a problem with how we've been
thinking about it so far yes we can do
we can do a zero knowledge proof for for
3-coloring based on Blum I agree so good
here's another I needed to I needed to
use this nice commitment scheme in order
to do fetch aamir for the hamiltonicity
protocol and you can ask if you can do
it from a trapdoor list commitment
scheme like a standard you know a
one-way functions based commitment
scheme I have no idea how to instantiate
Fiat ramier for that based on standard
assumptions of course the million-dollar
question is doing free a trimmer for
Killian this seems way harder it's not
even a proof so it definitely doesn't
fall into this framework but I think
that there's still a good chance that
some of the ideas from this line of work
can be used to say something about the
case of Killian I guess again this this
work on future mer Killian already said
a little bit about it I think that
there's a lot there's a lot to say even
more generally you can ask you know what
properties of random Oracle's can we
improve ibly instantiates I mean this is
a super broad question so future Mir was
I think of it as least at least as a
sort of quintessential
random Oracle property that we have had
and still have a lot of trouble
instantiating based on standard
assumptions but there are definitely
others and it'll be interesting to see
if there's anything we can do maybe
making off the mole hardness assumptions
like this or maybe just maybe finding
nice new applications of correlation
intractability or related security
properties that we can argue about in a
similar way in order to do more than
we've already done that's all I want to
say thank you
[Applause]
so you say it was strange we couldn't go
why the hidden bit small do you think
it's going to be strange that for laughs
you are and things like that we can't go
why the theatre Miro at least not you're
saying how you mean how reasonable do
you think it do I think it is to be able
to instantiate pietre me are based on
non lwv assumptions it's a good question
I of course I've given it some thought
who wouldn't
I don't know right now the construction
we the standard assumptions based
construction we have is is basic is
using homework encryption even the the
later chris messina results it's not
like explicitly using homework
encryption but it but it still is and we
don't have this based on other
assumptions I think maybe the rights
direction to think about here is can we
not use homework encryption but some
weaker form of homework that
cryptography that you can instantiate
based on based on other assumptions like
homework fixed secret sharing is one of
the first things you might think of in
this line you know so I would say maybe
the right question is can you use any of
these weaker homework objects to
instantiate correlation intractability
as well I think it's a good question I
don't know the answer yet but I think it
could be used if you don't care about
like
and you can get from the same
assumptions you can get this some
something like amorphic encryption for
branching programs well yeah it's not
quite the same i mean i've bit what you
can get you can't get yeah during a
question I don't know the answer but
maybe yeah so we know snarks from these
like really strong assumptions and then
physics from these other assumptions do
we know any assumptions that give both
zero knowledge and the sickness under
linear transformation oh I I didn't
think about it but you can probably
modify g'kar to make it zero knowledge
rights and you can probably then apply
something on top of that I don't take my
word for it but I expect you can
probably do it so the result we have
this succeed this for the genetic
languages we put in money to mr. damages
your staff to the witness time
oh I see I see I see I see
yeah good so yeah so this is why we have
to be careful when we use the word snark
like the the gkr protocol is for only
deterministic languages rights so if
you're already yeah you're already
thinking about NP languages yeah sorry
I'm not actually sure off the top of my
head like how you would like actually
write this down but I guess you were
saying like so people it's it of course
not no I mean that's I see yes so I
start I let again we definitely do not
get snarks for all NP languages we you
can only get succinct arguments for
languages that are already in P and so
this is a this is a quote yes the
verifier is running very quickly like
way way faster than time to decide the
language and the and the message is
shorts but we don't have this for NP
languages that would basically amounts
to doing fetching here for a Killian
style protocol and we don't know how to
do that
if you have more questions and there's
lots of products during the break and
the things that
[Applause]
[Music]